hi I'm Ted bellacor with reason TV and
today i'll be speaking with lex mcmahon
McMahon manages mixed martial arts
fighters in his president of Alchemist
management Lex you've got a very
interesting story about how you got into
MMA tell me about it yeah sure i was i
was writing about MMA and I was also
doing some sponsorships from MA but I
also was negotiated a contract for my
father who was at McMann the admin of
first and foremost a colonel in the
Marine Corps also happened to be a
tremendous icon within the entertainment
industry but I'd negotiate a contract
for him to be in a commercial for super
bowl MC Hammer was in that commercial as
well and Hammer and I hit it off
instantly on the set and one of the
first conversations we had was about MMA
and you know it really evolved from
there so we jumped in and launched
alchemist management and we're excited
great things ahead and you manage
roughly 13 fighters right that's correct
we had we have a boutique firm when we
focus on providing kind of a different
level of service to the guys it's it's
the social media marketing we have a PR
firm that's on staff to us we really
give the guys kind of a higher level of
service than what has been seen
previously and you manage some big names
like Nate Marquardt Jorge Rivera for
those who aren't MMA fans yet who were
will be soon right who are some of your
your top fighters you certainly
mentioned you know some of the top guys
Nate Marquardt is one of the top three
fighters in the world in his weight
class nicest guy you'll ever meet
Brendan Schaub who's fighting october
twenty third and his nickname is a
hybrid played professional football
Anthony hard on Vladimir Mancha shinko
we have or hey Rivera the El
Conquistador
let's take a step back and talk about
what I think is the the fascinating
evolution of the sport early on Senator
John McCain called the sport like human
cockfighting when the UFC came about
when mixed martial arts was really kind
of coming more to the forefront you know
rules were almost absent no referee no
weight classes it was 22 guys get in one
man leaves that was sort of the the
mentality you could pull hair you could
hit the guy on the groin 300-pound guy
fighting 180 pound guy I mean it just
there really because of those aspects it
was they weren't able to get sanctioned
in many states ultimately pay-per-view
was no longer carrying and so it became
this pretty much cult followed sport
that was very difficult to market but
what happened was Dana White the
frittatas they got involved they
purchased the UFC you know some years
back and they've done a tremendous job
evolving the sport growing bringing it
more mainstream one of the first things
they did was they added weight divisions
they added a referee so it's gone from
human cockfighting to at the fastest
growing sport the fastest growing sport
in the world
one of the interesting points you made
was the how there are market incentives
to add some rules to bring it to a
larger audience you're not going to get
beyond the hardcore cage fan folks
unless you do that correct no I think
that's absolutely correct i mean i think
what what has begun occurring is that
the rules have been put in place you're
getting a higher level of sophistication
in both the business and in the athlete
as well as the folks that are working
with him a flea by taking control of an
athlete's brand and helping them to to
develop themselves as more than just a
fighter you know you begin to move away
from the human cockfighting and helping
people to understand that this is a
professional athlete but they're also
you know many cases you know great
family people you know philanthropist
doing a tremendous amount for their
communities and these are these are
things that will help the mainstream
sponsors embrace of these for you may be
surprised I enjoy the symphony from time
to time except the yoga hate the oboe
and I think it's ironic that there was a
people like John McCain who are leading
the charge against MMA in the in the
early days are also big fans of boxing
and it seems to me that MMA is actually
safer than boxing because you can attack
the entire body you can do striking with
you with you both your feet in your
hands but you also go for submissions
takedowns so there's less impact to the
head and although there are rules now
there's still few and defined you can't
pull hair you can't gouge eyes they're
clear rules of what you can and cannot
do but beyond that it's let the best man
win and that's allowed for a lot of
innovation in the sport that's where you
see can you talk about that because it
wasn't that long ago where hoist Gracie
seemed invincible then Matt Hughes
seemed invincible sure well I mean I
think what you see is let's keep mixed
martial arts okay that means it's in
embracing many different types of
martial arts in the early days you know
as you brought up hoisin in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu that was kind of the lead
martial arts with nmma because you could
control the body you could keep people
down it was an advantage to a smaller
person but once she started getting
people kind of the same level of
athleticism the same level of the same
size the advantages of BJJ became less
clear as more and more true athletes
have entered the sports as opposed to
just mixed martial artists now you're
seeing professional football players
like a Brendan Schaub come into into the
sport you know high-level wrestlers you
know world champions Olympic wrestler is
like a Joe Warren a matt lindland Randy
Couture those sort of people you know
they're bringing skill sets in and
athleticism in that maybe weren't there
before and with that new level of
athleticism there's more creativity also
because the sport has grown so much
you're seeing a substantially greater
number of people wanting to become
fighters with that greater number people
wanted to become fighters you're seeing
a broader sharing of ideas and concepts
and you have such an interesting
cultural mix too sure you get you know
bloody monsters inc
oh and Fodor from the former Soviet
Union you get your pen you get Brazil
you get all these different fighters
coming in and they're all bringing in
what their core disciplines were but
they're all having to learn new elements
you can't just focus in on one
discipline anymore I think that's why
you've seen you know the Gracie's not be
as successful as they once were because
the game has evolved so much and can't
be one to one dimensional because the
athletes that are coming as I mentioned
are just so more explosive Jon Jones a
great example is this you know he's 22
or 23 years old he's most explosive guy
in the sport I think is a pure athlete
or Rashad Evans you know he was a
wrestler but he's mean more the pure
athletes and they gave Georges st.
Pierre again look amazing athlete and
you've got all these guys like George
tan Pierre who you know look like he was
chiseled out of granite or something but
but then you've got Roy Nelson dealer do
you think that's part of the appeal of
the game because it's so much about just
results that you can have guys who are I
mean Roy Nelson looks like he's eight
months pregnant and yet he's still
wanted let it go I like Roy where he's
got a party ball he doesn't have a
six-pack that's part of his appeal right
cuz he's every man that's what makes him
marketable he's not a guy like Brock
Lesnar who's so absolutely enormous that
no one can relate to it because there's
so few people that that are built in
that manner Roy's a guy who is very
marketable you I think it really boils
down to is technique really does play a
tremendous part in this sport that's why
it's not human cockfighting who are your
top pound-for-pound fighters not
necessarily ones that you represent us
in general as a fan and that's really
how I came to the sport as a fan I think
you have to include Georges st. Pierre
Rashad Evans I think there's no question
that Rashad should be considered in that
group you know I really do think that
that what you're going to see out of
Nate in the coming fight and soon
thereafter I think people will quickly
begin to say nate marquardt nate the
Great is one of the top half and our
fathers and oils
sure